(wind rushing)
(mouse clicking)
(electronics beeping)
- Special education services
in the San Francisco
Unified School District.
She brings much expertise as a principal
as well as the central
office administrator
in the role of special
education supervisor.
And we're looking forward
to hearing Jean's talk.
Thank you, Jean.
(audience applauding)
- Hi everybody, wow.
I loved your talk.
I think I could have sat
and listened to it all day
because there are so many things
that we're doing together.
Although my office is
way out at the beach.
I'm at Santiago and 42nd, but we're doing
a lot of similar work for
the city of San Francisco,
which is exciting.
So this is my very first
keynote ever in my whole life.
I want you to know that.
So you're going to have
to bear with me, OK?
So my talk this morning is starting
with special education.
I was asked to come here
and basically give you
special education 101, sort
of what we can do together
and how you can access
and help your patients
access special education.
So I don't have videos.
I have a little bit of story telling,
but it's going to be somewhat basic
because that's what I was asked to do.
I would be happy to come back another time
and really let 'er rip from
my experiences in my career
in working with kids with special needs.
So we're starting with special education.
My name is Jean Roberson, I
am the relatively new chief
of special education.
I just had my one-year
anniversary two weeks ago.
And my entire career has
been here in San Francisco.
And I have had 20, I think,
oh gosh, I don't know,
26 years in San Francisco
Unified School district.
The disclosure page, yeah,
I'm just skip over this
if that's OK with you.
I did what they told me to do.
(audience laughing)
All right, moving on to my overview.
So what I did for the overview is just
to capture San Francisco's
overall vision and mission,
which this is actually our
Special Education Department's
vision where we provide
services and support
for our students with
disabilities and their families
that are characterized by quality, equity,
positive in-school and
post-school outcomes.
The department is led by me, the chief,
and is responsible for early intervention
for infants and toddlers,
pre-school for students
starting at age three, services
for school age children
in grades K through 12,
and transition services
for eligible students up to the age of 22.
And Chief Scott just told
me that his son graduated
from the access program
just at midyear this year,
so congratulations to your graduate.
So our learning objectives today.
I had to think good and hard
about what I wanted you to leave with.
And so I decided that the brief
description was important.
And it's vital that we
each understand our role
in Child Find, what the
assessment process is,
what an IEP really looks
like, and when things
when we're a little bit in disagreement
what the alternatives are to come together
and get through our disputes.
And so we call it the ADR,
the Alternative Dispute Resolution.
And that's prior to the smackdown
when you have to go to
the California Department
of Education or make an OCR complaint,
which is the Office of Civil Rights
if your child's or your patient's
rights are being denied.
I would hope that we could
come together before that
and work through whatever
the issues are together.
That's always been my goal, anyway.
I want you to understand
the lay of the land
of what's happening at
the school site level.
We have over 120 schools
in the school district,
and the schools are at different
levels of understanding
and implementation of the
laws around special education,
and it has to do with how
I like to use the word woke
our principals are, the
principals are in charge
of all things at their schools.
And if they're not woke
and fully understand
what's in front of them around special ed,
then we can run into a lot
of problems as a district.
So that training piece that
Chief Scott was talking about
is absolutely, it's
vital in the same thing
in our schools as well.
And I'm saddled with that responsibility.
We're also going to talk
about best practices
in collaboration together,
meaning us me and you
and the police of course as
well and all city agencies.
All right, so this is me.
I wanted you to understand
why I'm here and what I do.
The photo on the left is me as a teacher
at James Lick Middle School.
It was probably 1997 maybe.
That was about my third job.
I started out as a first grade
teacher here in the city.
I couldn't get a job
in the school district.
They weren't hiring at that
time, so I went private.
I worked at Discovery Center School.
It was the old Safeway
on Ocean and Alemany.
It was a very kind of
working class private school.
A lot of families weren't
doing public schools
back in the day, it was
a very diverse school.
It was the cheapest one in the district.
So I actually was exposed
to a lot of diversity
and working class families,
and it was a good place
for me to cut my teeth.
I taught first grade and I really learned
how to teach kids to read.
I was using a research-based
reading curriculum
and that was a wonderful
foundation for me.
I needed to clear my credential.
I cried, I had a baby, I
had to go back to college.
I couldn't believe it.
I thought, I can't do this.
And my principal at the
time handed me a paper
that spelled out a program at SF State
and said, "Go do this."
I said, "What is this?"
She said it's a program
for master's degree
in an administrator's credential.
I said, "I'm not doing that."
She said, "Do it!
"You're gonna lose your
credential if you don't."
So I said, "All right, how much is it?"
So I asked my mom.
My parents didn't pay
for much of my education.
I went to a college in
Rhode Island where I'm from
and commuted, I didn't live on campus.
I went on the cheap, that's how we were.
So I was their cheapest
kid, and when it came
to getting a master's they
were sort of into that,
so they helped me out a little bit
and got me through that master's program.
So at this job at James
Lick when that principal
encouraged me to go higher,
I was teaching seventh
and eighth grade, I was
a resource specialist.
I did have a special ed credential.
I always wanted to be a
special education teacher.
I was drawn to kids who
learned differently.
I was fascinated by them.
I found them mysterious and exciting,
and I wanted to get in their world.
And more than anything
I wanted to help them.
I was that kid.
So that was a wonderful job.
You can see I was thrilled and happy.
Most of my career I've
been thrilled and happy.
So after I got my master's
I also had another baby
in that time, so I have two girls.
So in 1999 I got my master's
I had my second baby.
(coughs) Soon after that
they made me be a principal
because we needed principals at the time.
My husband said, "You can
do it, I encourage you!"
I said, "I can't do it.
"I don't know the first thing
about being a principal."
He said, "You can do it, do it."
So he said, "I'll support
you the whole way."
So I took a job at
Grattan Elementary School
in the year 2000.
I had an 11-month-old baby
and a six-year-old daughter
at Harvey Milk Civil
Rights Academy at the time.
And I had a supportive husband.
And there's me on the first
day of school as a principal.
I stayed at Grattan, Grattan at that time
had five empty classrooms.
People didn't want to go to that school
and I love a challenge, I love
a fight, I always want to win
and I said, I'm gonna fix this.
And over the course of a decade,
I was there for 11 years,
that school went cray
cray, it went off the map.
People just came in droves.
They just wanted to be at that school.
And basically what we did,
we were just so accepting of everybody.
They asked me at that time
at that school, they said,
"Will you have a class for
kids with special needs?
"Autism is on the rise, we need a school
"to host autism classes."
And remember, I had five empty classrooms.
I was the special ed principal.
I said, "Of course I'll
take autism at my school."
And so that was the beginning
of a beautiful journey.
I have so many stories and
some of them involve police.
When our,
(audience laughing)
so it's making me think
about all the crossovers
that we have together, you
know, I had one kid with autism
who was attracted to Sutro Tower.
If you know where Grattan
is, it's down in Cole Valley
and Sutro is right up
the hill on Tank Hill.
And this kid was determined
to go to Tank Hill.
And so we had to put
the school on lockdown.
And well, one day he escaped.
And we knew he was missing,
so I always had the five-minute rule
'cause sometimes they're in therapy,
sometimes, 99% of the time
they're in the building,
just so you know, but every
once in a while they're not.
And so I have a five-minute rule,
and if we can't find him in five minutes
we have to call the cops, and so we did.
We ran around, well, we had
to call the cops that day
and they found him up on Rivoli,
just two blocks up alone.
A kid with autism tiptoeing and flapping
and looking for Sutro Tower.
So I just want to say thank
you to your police officers.
I've had three kids escape
in my 18 years as a principal
and two involved the
police, one I got myself.
But it's real, that's real.
And I'm not proud that kids
escaped, but they do escape.
If any of you have any experience
with kids on the spectrum,
(coughs) that notion of
finding that happy place
or that balance is very real.
And they'll do whatever
they can to get there.
So anyway, after my 11 years
there I sent to special ed
for a year because I got recruited
because I was the special ed principal.
And they said, Jean, we
want you to come over here
and do this supervisor job.
I did it for one year, there
were 21 schools under my
supervisorial genius I guess,
whatever you want to call it.
It was nuts, one of the
schools in that time
was Glen Park School, who had
had a principal for 29 years,
and they had two special day classes
and when I went to that school
and I saw the conditions
at Glen Park School
compared to the conditions
at Grattan school I just
felt such a compelling draw
to go back to a school and
help that community build
and grow a program that is
noteworthy in a positive way.
And I wanted to be with the kids
in building a community,
so I went back to a school
and I stayed at Glen Park for six years
until Dr. Matthews started
as our superintendent.
(coughs) And he asked me
to apply to be the chief
of special ed because he
felt I was right for it
for the reasons that I, whatever,
I'm not gonna get into that.
He worked on me and I said
no, who would do that job?
That's an awful job, that's
the worst job in the district.
Being the chief of special ed is seriously
an incredibly difficult place to be
because we're not at
our best in our schools.
We're not always doing great.
We do do great things,
but we have problems.
We have a lot of pockets of
problems in our district as well
and it's a huge endeavor.
Remember, I told you I wanted to win
and I wanted to make things great.
Well, I felt this might
be a little bigger than me
and I might not be up to it.
Anyway, they worked on me for six months
and I finally said yes, so here I am,
chief of special education
and I'm determined
to better the conditions in our schools
and in our city for
kids with special needs.
So I'm in for the long haul
as long as the Board of Ed
doesn't fire me.
So, as I said, my career
has been in San Francisco.
We are guided by these core values
and they absolutely speak to me.
Just seeing if there's anything else here.
No, we're gonna move on 'cause
we're making up some time.
Our mission is that
every day we provide each
and every student the quality instruction
and equitable support required
to thrive in the 21st century.
If any of you write me
an email and I respond,
my little tagline at the
bottom is whatever it takes.
Wholly committed to whatever it takes
in the life of a child.
So this sort of captures
that a little bit as well,
this notion of equitable support.
We are very committed to
equity in our district
because we have problems,
we have huge disproportionality problems,
and so this has bubbled up always.
And recently I was at a
superintendent meeting
and I noticed that in
this equity definition
that they were putting up, they put it up
in front of us every time there was a word
that was missing, and I was very upset.
And so I'm gonna read this to you
and then I want you to just think
what word may have been
missing that really upset me.
The work of eliminating
oppression, ending biases,
and ensuring equally high
outcomes for all participants
through the creation of
multicultural, multiable,
multilingual, multiethnic,
multiracial practices
and conditions; removing the
predictability of success
or failure that currently correlates
with any social or cultural factor.
Do you think you know the word?
It was multiable.
First of all, I don't even know
if I'd seen that word in print
prior to this definition,
but when I did see it it spoke to me.
I thought, wow, they
really, they called it out.
Ability awareness is so incredibly huge,
and what you were talking
about, Chief Scott,
is ability awareness on your police force.
Well, my school force,
whatever you want to call it,
that's the vital work that I have to do
is because there are
teachers of different levels
of understanding around ability awareness.
So that's part of my vision
in the work that I'm gonna continue to do
over the course of the next several years.
Vision 2025 is re-imagining
public education
in San Francisco for a new generation.
This is a document, it's
more than a document,
I mean, it's captured in a document,
but this was a process that took place
under the direction of Richard Carranza,
who was our superintendent
several years ago.
I loved Richard, I love most
people, I'm one of those people
I get fired up and inspired.
I loved the work in Vision
2025, and there's a lot in it.
And I was going to sort of bust out
some of what's great in it today,
but I need to cut back
a little bit on time,
so I'm not gonna go too into it.
I think that you're gonna have
these slides available to you
so I encourage you to
look into Vision 2025,
but basically what it
is, is truly re-imagining
what schools look like and
how we educate our kids.
I'll just pop this out for an example.
You're doctors and
clinicians, you know so much.
When you think about a middle school kid
and sort of what's happening
in their body around
not only hormones, but
their sleep patterns,
I have to question, beg the question
why do we make middle
school kids go to school
at 7:00 and 8:00 o'clock in the morning
when their bodies are so
completely upside down
and they don't really
settle down and go to sleep
until midnight or 1:00 in the morning.
Like, that's their rhythm in their bodies,
so I would hope that as
we go towards Vision 2025
that we're thinking about not
only imagining environmental
space, our time limits
on kids, how we get kids
to show what they know, why
we're still bubbling in bubbles
on norm-referenced
tests is just beyond me.
Kids have multiple
intelligences and it's important
that we capture their
genius and their brilliance
in a way that they're comfortable
and what's right for them
in sharing their brilliance and genius.
So I'm gonna move on from that.
Part of the Vision 2025
is the Graduate Profile.
So I'm just gonna leave
this up here for a minute
and let you take a quick look.
This is what we're hoping
that our graduates will have
at the end of their tenure.
I love the creativity piece.
If that was valued when I was growing up
I would have been a genius.
(audience laughing)
OK, the next slide, these are
my friends just so you know.
These are my kids, and I have
so many beautiful pictures
that capture 18 years of
running a show in the district,
but I had to be really
mindful of privacy laws.
But this is Mr. Scott and his crew,
and I thought I'd just throw
one little slide in there
to give you a glimpse of the beauty
that I get to spend my days with everyday.
So you pretty much know what
developmental disabilities are
I would hope, but I did
capture a quick definition
from the Centers of Disease
Control and Prevention.
And I'm gonna move on.
And you know who is affected.
Developmental disabilities
occur among all racial, ethnic,
and socioeconomic groups.
It's an equal opportunity condition.
Recent estimates in the United States
show that about one in six,
or about 15% of children
aged three through 17 years have one
or more developmental disabilities.
And these are some of them listed here.
So, in my world it all starts
with the federal mandate
of IDEA, the Individuals
with Disabilities Act.
It's the law, I love saying it's the law.
My teachers when they would
try to sneak out of something
or come up with a new
idea that wasn't quite
within the parameters of the
law I would always just say,
it's the law like it's non-negotiable.
And then not only just
saying it's the law,
but we say it's what is right for kids.
We always followed it up with,
this is what is right for kids.
It's a law for a reason.
So the primary purposes of
IDEA are to provide a free
appropriate public education
to children with disabilities.
We call it FAPE.
You know we're the acronym
capital of the world, OK.
IDEA requires schools to
find and evaluate students
suspected of having disabilities
at no cost to the parents.
Once kids are identified
as having a disability
schools much provide them
with special education
and related services like
speech therapy and counseling
to meet their unique needs.
The goal is to help students
make progress in school.
This progress thing is very real,
and I could do another whole
20 slides just on progress,
progress monitoring, how
often we get in trouble
for not progress monitoring.
That is a big, big litigation
issue in our district.
And I imagine it is in many
districts, but this is key.
We have to write
appropriate goals for kids
and then we have to watch them.
And we have to collect data
and map, how are they doing
just like you do in your work.
I imagine you're looking to
see how kids are developing.
And you have your little
charts and percentiles.
I know you do, I have two kids, remember.
It is also to give parents a voice
in their child's education.
So I have a little anecdote on this one.
Remember that first slide
when I was in my 20s
at James Lick Middle School
is when I really first
started writing IEPs.
Prior to that I had just
been a college student
and did practice IEPs,
and then I taught gen-ed
for six years in the first grade.
So when I went to the middle school
I had to start writing IEPs.
And oh, I thought I was great at IEPs.
You know, I'd sit there
and connect with the family
and talk about the kid and after one IEP
my partner at the school counselor Palel.
I'll never forget him, he's a good guy.
He was so kind, I'm so blessed
that I've had kind people around me.
I've had maybe not so kind people,
but the kind people are the ones
that shaped my behavior as an educator.
And he put his hand on mine and he said,
I said, "How did I do, how was that?"
He's like, "That was great."
He said, "But, you really
never let the parents speak.
"You did almost all of the talking."
And I remember it was like a gut punch
'cause I thought I did great, you know,
here I am like, woo-hoo!
He's like, you never
really let the parent share
what they needed to
share about their parent.
And luckily, I can honestly say this,
luckily that happened very
early in my special ed career
so I was mindful of that
forever on afterwards
that that parent's voice and input,
they are the expert of
their child hands down.
They know their kid better than anybody.
I was an expert of 28 kids.
I had a caseload of 28
kids, so I had my case load.
I always say, the
principal's an expert of 350
or 400, whatever their world is,
but that parent has the most information
from a really unique standpoint.
And I hope that you always were valued
and had good input in
your IEPs for your son.
And that is something that I will focus on
very strongly and carefully
in my new role as chief
is to get schools and my
people who support the schools,
I have a whole staff that
support the 121 schools
to really value, and
not act like a big shot
like we're know-it-alls
'cause we're not know-it-alls.
So that's another part of IDEA.
The third part I wanted to mention
is the IDEA covers children
from birth through 21 or 22
depending on where their birthday falls
and it provides early intervention
which we all know is key through age three
into the public schools.
And we also have to support
kids in charter schools.
We even support some kids in
the private school sector.
That's another 20-slide presentation
about how vast our commitments
are as a public school
Department of Special Education.
It's not just the 121 schools
in the comprehensive system,
but it's also throughout this entire city.
We are the city and
County of San Francisco,
so we're our own SELPA,
which stands for the Special
Education Local Plan Area.
Oftentimes it's county-wise
and there's lots of districts in a SELPA
and then they support each other
and they get funding that way.
So I'm also the SELPA director.
Not only am I the, see, I told you
this was the hardest job in the district.
I'm the chief and the SELPA director,
so it's the entire city.
So it's nuts.
But I'm here basically to tell you today
that teamwork makes the dream work.
Now, this sounds dorky and
I've been known to say it
on a daily basis, and we
used to laugh at each other
at the school site, and
when I went up to the beach,
the Santiago Special Ed Department
I started saying it there.
I actually got pushback from
one of my people who said,
"You know, why do you say that?"
That's just, you know, she didn't like it.
And she's like, I have
my team, this is my team.
So she's got a division of special ed.
And she talks to her team, and so we had
to kind of have a little
bit of a smackdown
on why we're gonna say this,
and you have to buy into this.
We're in this together.
But I'm also here to tell you today
that I'm in this with you as well.
And basically I think that's
why I was invited here today.
I want to give you a glimpse into my world
and I want to let you know
where we can cross over
and do this work together
and hopefully by the end,
and I'm watching this clock,
and we can do some Q and A,
but some of my greatest,
and I'm most proud of work
is the work that I've done when I was able
to cross over with the medical
professionals in this city.
That's when we did our greatest
work, so, here you are.
Early intervention is vital.
The parents are on the front line,
so they get a little
inkling when something
might not be OK with their kid.
Where if any of you are parents
you know what your gut is
telling you on any given day.
I have a kid, I had a kid on an IEP.
I cried like a baby on the day
that her teacher came to me and he said,
"I think we should do an assessment,"
'cause I knew in my
heart that my kid wasn't,
I don't want to say normal,
she was broken, she was not OK.
My daughter was not OK, and
she was really struggling.
And we're Kaiser, we were a Kaiser family,
and God bless her pediatrician.
She was my greatest, greatest partner
in the work with my daughter.
My daughter's great,
she's a self-advocate.
She's 19, she's a sophomore
at Portland State.
She wants to cure cancer,
she's a math nerd scientist.
She wants to wear a lab coat.
She doesn't really want
to deal with people.
She wants to work with test
tubes and Petri dishes I think,
but she wasn't OK as a little girl.
She had the wigglies, we
called it, the wiggles.
She had some repetitive behaviors,
some OCD stuff going on.
High anxiety, wouldn't
transition, just nightmarish.
Working mom, you know, the
kid that wouldn't leave school
at the end of the, I
mean, that was just awful.
It was horrible, anyway,
I cried because I knew,
I knew, I knew, so we got her assessed
and plugged her into a resource program
where she had an advocate
and she got a lot of help
with her executive functioning.
And I didn't have to do it.
My parenting stopped
basically at that point
and she took off on her own
once she knew what her conditions were.
I remember the day, too, she
said, "I need a therapist."
I said, "Go to the Wellness Center."
She went to Mission High.
I said, "They have a
great Wellness Center."
She said, "I don't need a counselor Mom,
"I need a therapist."
(audience laughing)
I was like, oh.
I said, "Well, go call one."
You know, I was like,
I work all day, sister.
Anyway, she's doing
great, but it wasn't easy.
So I put this slide up just because,
honestly because I'm here with you today
but also my experience is absolutely
a firm, strong partnership with
her pediatrician, big time.
So I wanna tell you quickly a little bit
about who we are in
special ed and what we do.
So, I have data, just a little bit.
This, can you read this?
The numbers, is the font big enough?
OK, try to, when I asked my
statistician guy to do this
it was tiny, I said they're
never gonna be able to read this
but basically this is a pie chart
showing all of our 7,590 kids on IEPs
and what their breakdown is.
And I don't know why it
says category name, value
up at the top, that's fascinating.
Oh my God, they're all different.
That's not what it says on mine.
So let me just tell you.
(audience laughing)
It didn't transfer correctly.
So the big part of the pie is
specific learning disability.
The second going down is
speech and language impairment
is 18.2%, autism is 15.8%,
other health impaired is 14.6%.
Intellectual disability
is the yellow, that's 5%.
Emotional disturbance is
the gray, and that is 4.7%.
Low incidence is 2.9% and
hard of hearing is 2.3.
The emotional disturbance
one I always take issue with
because our kids who have many ACEs,
are you familiar with the term ACEs,
adverse childhood experiences?
Yes, OK, good, I figured you were.
Our kids who have trauma
and ACEs often get captured
and identified in that category.
I struggle with that greatly
because there's a predominance
of Black children in that category
that come from poverty areas in the city
and I have to question
whether or not our conditions
on the general ed side in the Safe
and Supportive Schools side,
the work of my dear friend
and partner Kevin Truitt, if
we're not doing enough there.
If we did a better job on the front end
creating conditions to
address ACEs in our schools
then I have a funny feeling that
that data point would be less.
So that's something
that I'm very mindful of
and I'm going to be working on.
Unfortunately Kevin tells
me he's retiring soon
and I'm very sad about that
because we have a lot of work
to do together still.
All right, moving on to the next slide.
Educational setting, so now
you know we have 7,590 kids
on IEPs, and in the big gray space here
is the RSP program, so
about 60% of our kids
are in the RSP program
and in the yellow 17,
almost 18% are speech and language only.
So about 75% of our
kids are all general ed.
We consider them general ed kids.
The orange is special day class,
and the blue are kids
in non-public schools.
That's another conversation.
There's a lot going on with
our kids in non-public schools.
And it's actually, well,
that's 20 more slides.
I'll come back next year
and we'll talk about that.
Kids on the autism spectrum.
So at the bottom of this
on the left hand side
is the year 2000, which
is the year I started
at Grattan Elementary School.
And I believe in about 2004
is when we got our first class
for kids with autism that
was specifically for kids
on the spectrum was at Grattan.
And here we are today at 1,241 kids.
And we have autism-focused classes
throughout the district now.
It's on the rise, and
it's not just because
we're better at diagnosing, trust me.
I've spent the last 18 years of my life
immersed in a K5 educational setting
and I can tell you that Asperger's
and autism is increasing.
Firsthand experience.
Don't even argue with me.
(audience laughing)
All right, the ethnicity of our students.
And I had to put this in
because of my concerns
around disproportionality.
Back to the emotional
disturbed and the ACEs
and we are just
overidentifying kids of color,
and it's a problem in our district.
At the same time, we can miss kids
with discrete learning disabilities
because we don't want to overidentify.
We have a lot of work to do
in the area of disproportionality.
We're being watched by the
state, and we do a lot of work
cross-departmentally to address this.
Have we banged it home yet?
No, I'm still in the game.
There's a lot of people
who are focused on this,
and we will continue to take it on.
So, now that parents know
that they may have a kid
who has been identified,
they have to enter
into the world of special education.
Our reputation is not
stellar, let's all face it.
People talk about special
ed, I know they do.
And so this is where I'm going to appeal
to all of you today.
Child Find, it's a
process that requires us
to identify, locate, and
evaluate our children
with disabilities residing
in our jurisdiction.
The obligation includes all students
who attend private
including religious schools,
migrant or homeless students
who are wards of the State,
and students with suspected disabilities
who are still advancing in grade levels.
I think it's worthy to note
that you're on the front lines.
We went, that slide in the back,
if you have even an inkling
of suspicion you should bust
it out and you should write
a letter to the principal.
You should encourage the
parents to get into the schools.
Not every principal receives
those letters from doctors
or parents in a way that's lawful
because they're not schooled
correctly in the law.
That's my job, it doesn't
mean that you don't do it
or you get frustrated in the process.
And later on in a couple more slides
I'm gonna show you some
resources in the city
that you should have on your Rolodex
so that if a parent comes back to you
and says they hit a snag
or they hit a roadblock
or something didn't
happen, then you need to go
to the next step and just
push and push and push.
When we get a letter from a doctor
that says do an assessment on this kid,
more often than not,
I'll be honest with you,
when you wrote letters to me
and told me about your patient
and it was my kid I was like, mm-hmm.
More than likely we had already
had a couple of meetings
on the books and we were maybe
in process or ready to go.
We're in cahoots, in other words.
Very seldom does something
come out of left field,
and I'm like, yeah, no, that's ridiculous.
But if we did have that
feeling of, that's ridiculous
we still by law have to
write that parent a letter
saying this isn't going
to happen and this is why.
And then of course we would go
to the Alternative Dispute Resolution
'cause the parent would say,
yes, I want this to happen.
And eventually more than
likely it would happen.
(coughs) Excuse me.
So the referral, we just talked
a little bit about the referral.
Basically make the
referral, don't hold back.
I'm moving a little quickly
because I want to make sure
we have time for Q and A.
Navigation is key, and this is, again,
you're going to need a
support person along the way.
So it's important that
you have those resources
to direct parents accordingly.
And I'm going to give you
some before we leave today.
Anybody basically can
ask for an assessment.
Obviously the parent,
a caregiver, a teacher,
the principal, the doctor, all of that.
A child, you know this, I
hope you know this already,
but a child with a
disability may be eligible
for special education if
they meet the criteria
under one of these 13 disabilities.
The IEP, the IEP.
The bottom line is the IEP's the meeting
where you all come to the table.
Obviously I can't say that I've ever had
a medical professional at the table.
I have absolutely called a doctor.
If I get a release of information,
we'll skip over that slide,
it's a few more ahead.
If I get the release of information,
if a parent wants us
to talk to one another
we absolutely will and we should.
And all of your great
information will be considered
and brought to the table
when we're creating
a program for a child.
An IEP is not just a
meeting, it's a process.
Anybody on the team can
say it's time to meet again
or I have some concerns or I'm not sure
if that's an appropriate goal.
So we try to consistently
bring the team together
for what's right for a kid.
So sometimes it can get nutty.
People want part six, part seven.
That's when we start to not get along
very well with each other.
There's a sweet spot in there.
I would encourage parents
and educators to find
the sweet spot so that we're
not burning each other out.
Services, an IEP may include specialized
academic instruction, related services,
the use of supplementary
aids and services,
curriculum accommodations and
modifications, which is huge
and has been underutilized in my opinion.
I want the teachers and the
principals at the schools
to get more creative with
accommodations in the classroom.
And a range of other services
individually designed
to provide educational benefit.
The least restrictive environment
is the general education setting.
We try, I think the next slide
sort of has a picture here.
So the least restrictive is
gen ed with some supports,
and then it's gen ed with some push-in
with a special ed teacher
in the room helping out.
The next level is general
ed where you get pulled out
for some intervention, so maybe
some daily reading intervention
to bolster your reading.
We have self-contained classrooms
where kids spend more
than 50% of their day
in a special class, but we always should
be pulling them out to the
greatest extent possible
to be with their peers on the other end.
There are special day schools.
We don't have any
necessarily in our district
but they are in the non-public range.
That's our non-public schools.
Some kids have to go to
residential treatment centers.
I don't even want to discuss
detention facilities.
I have had students go to
the Juvenile Justice Center.
It breaks my heart.
Luckily I'm a street soldier
having worked with Joseph Marshall.
Do you know Joe?
Thank you, Street Soldier.
Back in the day, that was
the best training I ever had.
Training, I'm telling you
it's real, you know that.
And lastly is hospital and homebound.
And we work, when I was at Grattan
we had a ton of kids up at UC up the hill
in the oncology ward
where had siblings of kids
in the oncology ward and we'd
hold spaces at Grattan school
so the families could have access
to a little neighborhood school.
And so we did some great
work crossing over.
I learned a lot about
what that's all about.
So this just sort of spells out
the greatest access to general ed.
I'm gonna move on 'cause
we're almost done.
All right, you guys need to know this.
This is important for you
because you're on the front line
with the parents, they
have to have meaningful
parent participation, so you
need to school them on that
and remind them that if
they're going into an IEP,
remember my story when I talked too much.
There are teachers out there
who are still talking too much
'cause I haven't trained them yet.
Parents trained me, I want
to be honest with you,
the parents in this city have schooled me
on so, so, so, so much in my career.
So the parents can be
their own best advocate
and say, it's my turn to talk,
or you need to consider my input
and kind of advocate for themselves.
The next parent right
is prior written notice.
If they ask for something we
need to write back to them.
So for instance, that referral.
If they want a referral and the school
absolutely thinks there's
no referral necessary
we don't just say no, we
have to write back to them
officially and tell them why
we don't think it's necessary.
If they ask for their own iPad
and we don't think they
need their own iPad,
which by the way, that's
not even an issue anymore
'cause almost all kids have access
to iPads all day now anyway.
Anyway, we would write back to them.
So prior written notice,
they have to get
everything back in writing.
And when there's a disagreement
there is an absolute
avenue for them to take.
It's called ADR, Alternative
Dispute Resolution.
Progress monitoring, we already talked
about the importance of that,
so I'm not going to read that slide.
You know that our job is
to monitor their progress
and to readjust as necessary.
If we're not progress monitoring
then we're breaking the law
and you need to tell the
parent to call us out on that
and then we're going
to come to an agreement
of how to move forward together.
Release of information can
go both ways obviously.
So that needs to be a
thoughtful discussion
with the parent as to whether or not
you want to sign off on that.
It has to do with trust, in my opinion.
So if a family is feeling
that there's some trust
on the other side at
the school, as I said,
I was that special ed principal.
I think I did gain the
trust of many of my families
or if not, most of my families
and we were able to do
great, great things together
for their kids because
we trusted each other,
but I don't take for granted
that that isn't always the case.
Just know that that's out there.
I have three final slides.
I'm part of Our Children
Our Families Council
in San Francisco, are
you familiar with that
at all Chief Scott?
It's a coming together of city agencies.
It's basically the major
and the superintendent,
and we're popping out certain issues
and we're wrapping around
it as a city together.
We've been looking at attendance
since I've been chief.
That's another 20-slide presentation.
We have a huge attendance
issue in this school district
predominantly among
children with disabilities
and children of color, it's not OK.
We can't teach 'em if they're not there.
This is me, Special Education Department.
That is the main phone number.
For years when you called
that number nobody answered
or it went into some
byzantine, horrible place.
I actually should've put
my cell phone down there.
I would've done that
'cause I don't answer it.
I always just retrieve
messages unless a name pops up.
I hate ringing phones, it's my ADHD.
Anyway, we're on the website,
RobertsonJ1 is my email,
RobertsonJ1@sfusd.edu, we
can talk about that more.
This is the slide that you need to have.
This is an absolute must.
And our Support For Families
partners are in the house.
Woo-hoo!
Yep, they do deserve.
(audience clapping)
They are the hardest working people.
And I love, it doesn't say
hotline, it says warmline
because they are warm demanders.
They're so forgiving, but
they're fierce advocates
at the same time, that's a
dance, that's a fine line
and they're great at it.
And this is who you call
when you don't get answers from us, OK.
- [Woman] And also parents of--
(shuffling papers drowns out speaker)
- And so this is my final slide.
- [Woman] That's good.
- Your timing is perfect.
So I just want you to
know that this little guy
is doing a time out, and
he is chewing a chew stick
as you can see, and he's
absolutely fine and happy
and got right back into the class,
but this isn't acceptable
on so many levels
and in so many schools, and
so it needs to be acceptable
because that's what he
needed in the moment.
His time out needed to be
upside down with a chew stick.
So just remember, accommodations are key.
I'm sorry I had to go a
little fast at the end,
but I want to thank you for your attention
and I'm happy to be a partner
with you in this work.
(audience applauding)